what outcome do you have of going after
annelise michelle like what did you do
with that
like let's play the game and go in the
devil's conference room with 12 other
masters and you know advisors sitting
there okay let's go after annelise
michelle what's your outcome what a week
you know how much weakness you're
showing if you're going after a helpless
16 year old kid what do you think you
did you didn't do anything special but
then see then that that's a great point
then the devil is showing his true
character
so the devil believes he's doing
something that's advancing his agenda
his kingdom but ultimately all that ends
up doing is advancing the kingdom of god
then maybe we shouldn't be afraid of the
guy which never no one should ever be
afraid of the dead
because because because the point then
becomes he's not as strong as you think
he is
it's through your imagination that if
you let your imagination let loose
that's where he destroys you
because he makes you believe there's a
thousand people around the corner that
got his back that will fight you he's by
himself